[موسيقى]
جيروم لقد رأيت سيارات الدفع الرباعي الأخرى من طراز d-day
موديل 2020 وهي ثمانية مقاعد
ولديها تقنيات جديدة لن تجدها
سوى نماذج أغلى بكثير
[موسيقى]
عزم الدوران الموجه لسيارات الدفع الرباعي أو الدفع بالعجلات التي
تجدها  فيما يتعلق بالرؤية التكنولوجية ،
ترى كثيرًا أن فكرة Saba
[الموسيقى
] وميزات استنشاق النزل
تجعلها متاحة
لعملائنا في الشرق الأوسط
وللاستمتاع بالراحة في الإمكانيات
وشاشة عرض رؤوس التكنولوجيا هي
مقبس آخر '  ll ذريًا لشحن
الهاتف ، إنه المغرور هوارا ،
المقاعد تتحدث لغة التاميل على إمالة
[موسيقى]
تيلورايد هي سيارة مثيرة للغاية
ونحن متحمسون لإتاحتها
لجميع أفرادنا في الشرق الأوسط
بالإضافة إلى رحلة صغيرة لعام 2020
[موسيقى  ]  أنت